hey guys i'm ryan right supposed to be
crazy so there's a video from I'm Dante
message for Ryan right I roasted him
back there's apparently a lot of well to
put it bluntly [ __ ] idiots out there
who think that I was being serious and I
was talking to Dante he's never serious
and you're hearing him speak just assume
it's never serious rhymes all butter
Ryan can't take a joke man and I'm like
if you guys ever seen a Comedy Central
Roast they are a million times wiener
than what I said and they say things
that are personal and very real all my
[ __ ] was made up you know they use
knives and they just jab you yeah how
was he making up [ __ ] about andante
anyway oh boy this is gonna be good you
look like the kind of guy that would be
at home doing Let's Plays by yourself
that no one's probably gonna watch you
pussied out on roasting people yeah it
could have been a little bit tougher on
everyone including us guy I decided to
say that he thinks I'm gay when you have
flowers on your shirt and you have a hat
oh it does not want to give it like
you're part of the gay Paree game like
in this pride parade nothing wrong with
being gay but if you want to make fun of
me for being gay you've got to admit to
yourself that your gaydar was picking up
on me you think incredibly slow it just
seems like you're a little bit on the
slower side you know like all the other
reacting gaiter Martin thought though oh
snap
based off the fact of how you can't
satisfy black men oh he's capitalizing
off of this really well
this is really good sure this guy
decided to say that he thinks I'm gay
when you have flowers on your shirt
flowers primer nothing wrong with being
gay but if you want to make fun of me
for being gay
you've gotta admit yourself
eggs are great registering is like and
if you're anything like Dante who
actually doesn't have any balls at all
he will shove a egg a hard-boiled egg
down his pants to make it look like that
he actually has testicles when in fact
they are just [ __ ] funny
[Music]
brilliant man brilliant no what is up
there you guys in all honesty me and
Ryan Wright are cool like I have no beef
with him thank you no problem saying
like you need to make a roast dedicated
just to him playing his ass get him oh
boy
another roast will come in the future
when that roast come and best believe he
will be the main event I'm just chilling
right now I'm gonna do my reactions my
movie with my random videos such as this
one cool and you know me just I'm gonna
get some more dirt so Ryan Wright if
you're watching watch what's you doing
no videos watch what you say in your
videos because writing it down and then
i'ma read it then I'll store it up here
I don't know why I did that just cuz I'm
a crazy guy so uh yeah material yeah
like to all my subscribers it's all love
Ryan right I just want to let you know
oh I'm not gonna kill you I'm just gonna
roast you really ever II one subscriber
I'm Dante seriously I know I put a text
of the roast video but I'm gonna say it
up front here subscribe to I'm Dante
that was [ __ ] hilarious it started
off like okay this is gonna be funny
he's just gonna do a fake reaction but
then he took it to a whole other level
with the fun editing and then the really
action he was getting in the know it
makes me feel great because out of
everyone hating on me the one person I
was like I don't want this person to
think I was being real was him
right no the fact that he knows I was
just [ __ ] around and he's [ __ ]
around back is really like settling
feeling like you guys knew you do that
but I'd never been established I feel
like a beautiful friendship between you
two has been created today yeah no I
really feel like this is gonna be quite
because I I messaged him like a couple
days ago saying like hey we should
figure out a way to collab he lives in
another state but I was saying like I
really like your content and stuff so I
want to see there's a way we can somehow
come up with a collaboration I mean I
mean there's so many ways the technology
the way it is today where you can get
together or even or whatever doesn't
matter yeah you know like my whole point
of being because I was saying Dante
wasn't mean that mean so I was like I'm
gonna be extra mean to make up for it so
I was extra mean but I was just [ __ ]
around I feel like when he does another
roast he's gonna go like [ __ ] brutal
I don't care if you go don't go brutal
on anyone but you better go as [ __ ]
hard as you can on me like really
[ __ ] brutal I'm gonna action all my
[ __ ] I said about you was all made of
crap I'm gonna watch more of your videos
and come up with like I'm gonna write
[ __ ] of what to actually say about you
so we're gonna have a little roast
battle okay man it's gonna be fun I'm
really excited for this this is gonna be
fun that was great that was amazing
I just appreciate how honest and amused
this whole thing we're music yeah thing
was like you know Holly was like
laughing this is something that like I
feel like I would have done yeah all
right cuz someone who's like clowning on
you but you like turn it into something
even funnier now yeah by giving a
response that someone wouldn't expect it
was very clever well anyway guys thanks
for tuning in
and thank you all who sent this video my
way if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
check out Alyssa P Crazy's channel a lot
of challenges and cool vlogs on there
and you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram Twitter vine and me on
periscope currently and subscribe to I'm
Dante Josh McElhaney hello Ryan my name
is Josh you are hilarious you make me
laugh usually when someone is hilarious
that does follow up a laughter thanks
for clarifying that even on my bad days
could you shout out my channel Josh make
one one one three it would be a dream
come true thank you you alright Josh
McElveen E Josh make one one one three
seven hundred sixty subscribers not bad
what do you do you do gaming related
videos you do mash up videos oh cool man
this is really cool stuff you should do
um you should do a mashup video of like
your favorite porn moments like I'm
talking like crazy ass porn baby you can
back me up on these categories because
she Mike my girlfriend has once
considered being part of these
categories like when she was single
there's you know there's the obvious
threesome videos but you know there's
also like let's just hop some good stuff
you can do mashups of your favorite like
gangbang videos cream pie gangbang
videos and keeps you guys know what a
cream pie is that's where you actually
come in the girl and and then they're
like drips
you could do like double vag videos a
double anal videos there was I once saw
a triple anal video that's insane
three penises one but it's kind of
impressive the positions they get in to
accomplish that how are your eyes no
lies your eyes I be concerned about that
lemonade bottle how I discuss tea this
is just content that exists out there
probably a very very bad idea and let me
just say if it's been thought of it's on
the internet doesn't mean you should
seek it out yes it does Josh you go jerk
off to the most disgusting porn there is